the Joe Rogan experience we want to
categorize people as being like you said
one or zero binary irritable like either
chosen or irredeemably careful with how
you talk or you get labeled in in one or
two of those categories and people are
so scared now communicate it's I had a
conversation with a friend a while back
and he we're crazy conversation it was
alcohol involved but he said something
really ridiculous he was saying that
maybe it's good that women get so much
money in divorce because of all the [ __ ]
they've been through from men over the
years and I was home buddy I'm like what
does it have to do with money and
divorce like if that's an individual
person that's getting money from another
individual person is she getting is she
collecting is this like reparations for
all the horrible things that have
happened for women and he goes well Andy
so he starts getting defensive he goes
well what about income inequality the
women have to deal with I go oh Jesus
I go well you know that's not real right
and he goes what do you mean I go it's
not like there have the same jobs it's
not like both women the man and a woman
are both male men they both do the same
amount of houses but the man makes a
dollar when the woman makes 70 cents
that's exactly what it is I go the [ __ ]
it is not what it is illegal it is
illegal already passed explain right
everybody walked on eggshells
everybody's like oh geez what are you
saying right you're saying income
inequality is not real right no it's not
not that it's not real there's so many
of those mic drop yeah raises that yes
you know kids and cages which of course
we don't want kids in cages but there's
a whole discussion to be had about
immigration yeah as opposed to just kids
in cage or Islamophobia of course that
is a real thing it exists but there's a
whole other discussion but just these
look the left often uninformed yeah they
just are but they have these bullet
points that they feel like they
definitely can shut a conversation down
that's what I mean they don't feel like
they have to learn a lot about a subject
yeah because you have these mic drop
sayings or phrases that just stop people
from talking
well I'd fortunately known the actual
statistics and so when we were talking
about I was saying no no they choose
different jobs and
so they negotiate for themselves
differently yes they need to negotiate
for themselves better well that's one of
the things when people accuse jordan
peterson to being sexist you know Jordan
Peterson literally counseled and coached
women how to be more assertive right
their jobs to get better raises sure
who's really explaining how to do this
and and and just even maybe possibly
against your better instincts to exert
yourself and show that you understand
your value and this is what men do and
this is why men get raises and
oftentimes women just kind of keep it to
themselves and they're a little nervous
about it but it is amazing I mean you
mentioned divorce
yeah they don't assert as well going for
a raise but oh the divorce thing they
come in as I can go both ways if the
woman is the one who has more money yeah
but when the [ __ ] does that ever happen
that's like women who beat up men women
beat men up to like when I hear that oh
my god I'd go to the gym yes you should
go to the gym man it's like these men's
rights [ __ ] are like there's so much
to make fun of men's rights guys but
well I had one of them on my one of my
comedy specials I had a bit about it
where they were saying do you know that
men get raped more often than women I go
yeah by other men you [ __ ] idiot
exactly chicks throughout their rape and
dudes what do you think elders are and
their tops
Abed Christina Hoff Sommers yes yeah I
love yeah yeah I love her to know she
was on our show recently and you know we
were talking about the fact that also
they don't bring up a lot of the time
that most of the horrible dirty jobs in
the world yes are done by men yeah
they're the ones who are up on the
telephone poles most likely died on the
job most likely to be murdered and most
likely to go to jail yeah most likely to
get a much longer jail sentence yeah for
the same crime so we're not crying about
being men
we're just saying as she says life is a
complex yes
mixture of advantages and disadvantages
yeah I think the pendulum swinging the
other way though I think really dumb
statements like [ __ ] all white men like
which used to hear on Twitter and people
used to like applaud and retweet it I
think people are now like um oh [ __ ]
well that's a little out there but I
have heard when now it's going in the
other direction because the race is
winnowing but at the point of say six
months a year ago when lots of people
were getting into the race at some point
there were 24 Democrats in there and
when a white guy would get in it was
very common to hear do we need another
white guy yeah
and that was completely okay yeah on the
left and it's like okay but then we are
saying that we are using race yes to
judge whether someone is qualified
well right yes Zach we are using race
and gender to say whether someone is
qualified just so we understand what
we're doing here because I don't think
that's exactly what Martin Luther King
meant when he said judge by the content
of their character and not the color of
their skin which seems to elude the
promised form of identity politics and
it's really ridiculously dumb when they
don't realize that that same sort of
strategy is gonna come right back around
at you it's like people to think the
other guy's pissing me off I'm gonna go
[ __ ] punch him well guess what he's
gonna punch you back like this is this
is not it's not that simple when you if
you go around judging people based on
their gender and their their color and
their race guess what they're going to
do that to you now like this is it's
horrible strategy
[Applause]